welcome to salz talks money on
valuetainment i'm your host adam sosnick
and i'm here
to help you yes you build your wealth
and save
that money on today's episode we're
going to be breaking down how you
can win the interest rate game
let's talk money all we talk is money
all we talk is money
now we've all heard that money's a game
and you got to get in the game to win
the game we're talking about capitalism
and building wealth and winning the
money game let me tell you something to
win the money game
the cornerstone of winning the money
game is winning
the interest rate game did you catch
that right there to win the money game
you need to win the interest rate game
so behind me what we have is a little
bit of
information for you to get real deep
into when we're talking about the
interest rate game now what you see
right here
a couple of key terms when it comes to
interest right here we have a little bit
of winning the interest rate game
and losing the interest rate game and
then we'll circle back at the end on
what it all means to you and how you can
win
the money game so with that being said
let's dive right in to the key
terminology when it comes
to interest now what is interest
interest
is this it's a fee paid to borrow money
no big deal there it's a fee
paid to borrow money cool we got that
now what is the interest rate the
interest rate is the amount
the borrower pays this is sometimes
called the apr or the annual
percentage rate then you have what is
known as compound interest compound
interest
is a lovely lovely lovely thing folks
compound interest is your interest
making interest and your money making
money on your interest on your money and
your money making interest
it's a beautiful beautiful thing i sound
like a rap video right now but that's
money on money on money on money
and that is a very magical effect in
fact i have a
quote for you here's the quote compound
interest is the eighth
wonder of the world he who understands
it
earns it he who does not pays it you
know who said that
only the smartest person to live in the
last hundred years mr
albert einstein now if you don't know
einstein folks you need to do a little
bit more reading
on your end so that's einstein so let's
talk about earning interest
versus paying interest earning interest
versus paying interest
now when you talk about earning interest
that is when you're being
paid on your money that is known as
investing that is
winning the interest rate game that is
also known as appreciation
a lot of good things over here
everything in green is what is known
as your best friend now speaking of best
friend
what's your worst enemy well your worst
enemy is you
paying interest that my friends is known
as debt debt is your money
going backwards as you can see this is
depreciation
this is losing the interest rate game so
let's go back to einstein
he who understands compound interest
earns it
he who does not pays it okay we got that
now as you can see behind me there's a
graph and we break down what it means to
win
the interest rate game and what it means
to lose the interest rate game
should we start with losing or winning
where should we start
we'll start with losing because we'll
finish strong at winning that's my
that's my take on this
all right cool so what does it mean to
lose the interest rate game that is in
red
and then green is obviously winning the
interest rate game at the top of the
chart you have
inflation inflation is a silent thief in
the night
that steals your purchasing power
without you even knowing it that's what
inflation is
now inflation on average over the last
hundred years ranges between two
and three percent i'll give you a quick
case example on inflation
50 years ago you wanted to buy a coke it
might have costed you a nickel
back in the 1980s 1990s you wanted to
buy a coke that was 50 cents
now it's 20 20 a coke is a dollar it's
still the same coke it just cost
a different price that is a quick lesson
on inflation
so inflation ranges between two and
three percent as we discussed now as we
go
down the line here this is from least to
most amount of
losing so let me say that again as we go
down the line here this is more and more
losing the interest rate game so next up
are mortgages mortgages right now are
freaking
all-time lows currently at mortgage
rates at two and a half
to four percent if you go back in time
1980s 1990s
interest rates were like 10 12 15 that's
crazy
now interest rates range between two and
a half and four percent now it might be
a great time
to look into getting a mortgage if
you're interested in buying real estate
cool moving on we got student loans
student loans you want to go to college
you want to take out 50 100 g's
to go to school to learn cool i get it
but you're gonna have to pay between
three
and six percent interest on your money
cool that's how student loans work now
you got car loans there's a difference
between car loans on new cars
versus used cars so what i have here are
ranges right so
there might be oh i got i actually paid
four percent but you said that it's five
percent
these are ranges folks so just to
understand how these numbers work
on a new car you're looking at somewhere
around five percent on a used car
you're looking at somewhere around 11
again a car is a depreciating asset
some may call it a liability but either
way you're looking at between 5 and 11
depending on the type of car moving
right along you got business loans
you got a business you need to take out
a loan this can vary this can vary
that's why i got asterisks over here
you got different type of loans things
may vary we understand that
business loans can range between two to
seven to as much as 13
on a loan for your business moving right
along we got personal loans now personal
loan can range between six
and nineteen percent that's quite the
variance right there now what is a
personal loan
personal loan is basically a
consolidation of a couple different
loans that you might have you might have
a credit card that you're paying 10
interest on you might have a credit card
you're paying 20 interest on
you consolidate it into one personal
loan one account
and you're paying one number that's
basically a personal loan where you're
paying between
six and nineteen percent cool we got
that now let's move on to credit cards
we all got credit cards you go to
college your first day of college
there's people out there giving credit
cards
sign up sign up to give you a free
t-shirt cool cool cool you're signing up
for a credit card
next thing you know you're paying
between 14 and 18 interest on a credit
card
stop the presses folks you got to
understand that if you're paying
the minimum payment on your credit card
you might be paying
that minimum payment forever forever
forever ever like outcast said back in
the day
the last thing you want to be doing is
paying interest on a credit card
minimum minimum minimum you're racking
up between 14 and 18
in my opinion anything over five six
percent interest
now you're ending up in murky waters
certainly in double digits
it gets a little scarier right speaking
of scary let's talk about some of the
worst
types of debt that you can be paying and
this ends with cash advances
and payday loans cash advances and
payday loans cash advances is when you
want to take cash
from your credit card you might be
paying as much as 20 to 250
percent let me say that again as much as
250 percent
for a cash advance and then a payday
loan is when you got payday on friday
but you need money
on a monday so you go out for a payday
loan we've all seen these places on the
side of the road
come in for quick cash payday loan these
are astronomical interest rates
that can be as much as 400 and 500
percent
this is stealing money from yourself
this is the epitome of
losing the interest rate game if you can
please please please please
avoid cash advances and payday loans
they are not a good look and they will
only
kill your wealth with that said let's
talk about
winning the interest rate game now let's
winning the game now winning the game it
starts with stacking cash
and saving that money you know that is
my favorite phrase but here's the deal
with saving that money
you don't make interest on your money
the whole point of saving money and
stacking cash
is not to make interest and i'll give
you an example if you're saving money
and you got money in the bank it's in a
checking account or even a savings
account maybe maybe maybe you're making
between
point one and at the very most
one and a half to two percent let me say
that again stacking cash
is not about interest don't really focus
on the interest rate
just focus on stacking cash because
maybe you'll make between
point one and one and a half to two
percent on your money that's cash but
that's the beginnings
of winning the interest rate game then
from there you have what are known as
cds
or certificate of deposits that's what
you put your money in a bank
for six to 12 months you can't touch it
and you maybe make
point five percent on your money not
exactly winning the interest rate game
but it's better than losing so with that
being said let's talk about
what it starts to mean to win the
interest rate game then you have your
home appreciation
half of the people in america right now
are homeowners you understand about home
appreciation
on average if you have a mortgage and
you have a house
your home will appreciate over time
between three
and five percent cool you got it your
money
is making money on appreciation three to
five
percent over time cool then we got bonds
now we're talking about investments
now we're talking about government bonds
in this case on average this is
returning or yielding
right you know that word bonds yield
between five and six percent
over time now a bond just in case you
don't know is an iou to a company
or a government in this case is where
you lend money to the government
or a company and they pay you back over
time when the bond matures you can make
between
five and six percent on average these
are average numbers here
then you have the dow jones now and
we're talking about stock market
investing now we're just talking about
bonds
now in the stock market the dow jones
are the top 30 u.s stocks in america
these are top
blue chip stocks top top top top top
blue chip stocks
they yield on average seven and a half
percent if you're investing
in the dow jones index a lot of times
when you hear the market did this today
or the market did that today they're
often talking about
the dow jones but when you really want
to invest in the stock market it's not
necessarily the dow jones that you need
to be focusing on
it's the s p 500 we all understand that
the s p
500 has 500 of the largest companies in
america
within the s p 500 kind of kind of kind
of how that works
over time the s p 500 will yield 9.8
return on your investment not bad i'm a
big
big advocate of index investing in the s
p 500 go check that out if you're not
familiar with that
cool then we got reits i'm not a big
real estate investor
but i am a big reit investor what do i
mean by that
meaning i rent i've done episodes on
renting before why i rent and i don't
buy
i don't like to be tied down i like my
money moving i like to be able to
go with the flow and have flexibility
but i do invest
in real estate investment trusts reits
this is investing in real estate
commercial property residential
properties without having
to have a mortgage and be a homeowner so
check out reits on average reits will
return between
10 and 12 if you're renting and you want
to invest in the stock market
i highly advise you look into something
called reits
cool check it out then you got etfs
these are known as exchange
traded funds this is where you can buy
and sell
mutual funds as if they were certain
stocks i'm a big
buy and hold investor but if you're
going to look into etfs
these on average will return somewhere
around 12
not bad at all then we're moving on we
got hot stocks and crypto
now you see you can see that there's an
asterisk right here there's a plus or
minus 20 percent that's just kind of how
it falls on the chart
meaning you might have a hot stock or a
crypto portfolio of some capacity
that might make 20 30 40 50 100
investment crazy investments but you
could also
lose that amount of money so understand
that something like that just investing
in individual stocks
or something as far as crypto goes has
high risk and high reward
that's up here if you can win that game
but it could be potentially losing
so just proceed with caution when it
comes to buying individual stocks
or crypto but i felt the need to put
that on the chart moving right along
then you got businesses
people who invest in businesses are
looking for somewhere between 15
and 30 yield and business for all my
entrepreneur friends out there
i understand where you're at you don't
want to necessarily have a
2 5 6 10 return you're looking for a
higher
return on your sweat equity and putting
in the time and being an entrepreneur
investing in business cool i get it the
reward for that is somewhere between 15
and 30 percent
and if you completely kill it it could
be more than that
last but not least do you know what is
the highest on this list
the highest on this list a hundred
percent investment
well it's investing in yourself warren
buffett once said
the best investment you can possibly
make is investing
in yourself what does that mean that
means in getting smarter
getting stronger getting sexier getting
cooler getting more knowledgeable just
getting
everything that you want to be being the
best version of yourself
there is no better investment than
investing in
yourself cool you got it now that my
friends
is winning and losing the interest rate
game
so just to wrap that part up the best
investment you can possibly make
is investing in yourself the worst
is borrowing money from yourself to pay
yourself
it's a never-ending game it's like a cat
and mouse game that you can't win
so invest in yourself and definitely
don't do payday loans so that's the best
and worst of investing now let's get
back to where we started at the
beginning of this episode
which was winning the money game i said
that the interest rate game
or winning the interest rate game is the
cornerstone
of winning the money game now if you
have not seen my episode
on winning the money game we'll
definitely put a link of that at the end
of this episode but let me recap what it
means to win
the money game now understanding the
winning the money game there's six
principles of wealth there's not a
hundred different things you've got to
read 50 different books you've got to
take 100 different classes
be great at these six things i'll give
you a quick recap number one it starts
with a game plan a budget is a game plan
for your money understanding a budget
understanding your income
understanding your expenses
understanding having a net
worth mentality not a pay check
mentality that is
having a game plan for your money that
is numero uno number one
then you have number two the second
principle of wealth which is getting out
of debt we
just recapped what it means to be in
debt this is spending money this is
money
going backwards this is having a spender
mentality in a lot of cases
it's very important that if you're going
to win the money game you got to get out
of debt have a
payoff plan for your debt and then when
you can pay off that
now you can start getting into the
saving that money component and then
obviously the investing
so principle number three which i had
right here zing
right there save that money saving is
the key to wealth i encourage you as you
heard me say here before
save ten thousand dollars if you have
not done that i promise you promise you
promise you
saving ten thousand dollars is an
awesome awesome feeling
most americans have not done that you
might be saying well what do you mean
most americans not have done that i'm
telling you
most americans have not saved ten
thousand dollars in their life
so if you can do that and save that
money save ten thousand dollars
then my friends it is time to become an
investor we talked about
the benefits of investing and how much
interest compound interest
you can make when you become an investor
there's two key ingredients when it
comes to investing
time and compound interest time in the
market and your compound interest
as we discussed before that's interest
making interest and your money
making money become an investor then
after that you want to protect
everything you have you want to ensure
your biggest asset what is your biggest
asset well we discussed this earlier
it is you you are your biggest asset you
are your best investment
protect yourself that's health insurance
that's life insurance that's disability
insurance
god forbid something happens to you make
sure you're protected so once you've
done all those five things
then you can end up where you're
chilling and chilling is when you own
your time
you're out of debt you've saved that
money you've got investments going on
you're making compound interest
compound interest we understand it's the
eighth wonder of the world
it can be your best friend you become an
investor now
you chilling and that's it that's how
you win the money game
and the cornerstone of winning the money
game is understanding the interest rate
game
and just like albert einstein said he
who understands it earns it and he who
does not
pays it so now hopefully hopefully
hopefully you have a better
understanding of what it means
to win the interest rate game with the
good help of our friend
compound interest the eighth wonder of
the world and that's it that's the end
of this episode
hopefully you enjoyed this episode
hopefully you learned something if you
did
please leave a comment below just so you
know i read all the comments i respond
to the comments
i appreciate you taking the time out of
your day to learn something from these
videos
and drop in a comment and giving me your
feedback with that being said
if you have not seen this episode on how
to win the money game
the six principles of wealth we're gonna
put that for you right here
and if you have not seen this episode on
how to invest
then versus now check that out that will
help you
become a better investor today with that
being said if you have not subscribed to
valuetainment economics
please subscribe below and smash that
like button while you're at it and as
always save
that money all we talk is money